joining us now former deputy assistant
to the president Fox News national
security strategist Sebastian Gorka
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi Pam
thoughts Oh Sean it's like you said if
we were watching this on a movie I don't
think anyone would believe it how unreal
it is and what you've uncovered what Fox
is uncovered first of all all of these
people need to be wiped off the case
they need to start over there's no
question about that and I will say this
every time there are so many great men
and women in our federal government just
like you said but this has really gotten
out of control
I think Rhonda Santos asked some great
questions today trey Gowdy was great and
rod Rosenstein set there and answered
him and rod said something and I know
rod let me tell I'm know rod I've dealt
with rod and I have only had completely
ethical dealings with rod and that's my
hope right here he said something it is
their responsibility to be sure
influence do not have what else do we
need why don't their actions what we
need now is to get all of these other
people off the case and from hearing him
today
I think he's ethical I think all these
people need to be removed they're not
you change the route and he said he
thinks Muller's doing a good job I think
we need to hold on though Shaun and see
what happens I'm not defending Muller
I'm not defending Rosenstein right now
but what I'm saying is given everything
that you've exposed giving the
hard-hitting questions today that he got
at Congress let's see what happens now
let's see all of these people need to be
wiped out there are plenty of good
people out there who can handle a case
who have no influence they haven't given
to either party and as you said eight
out of the 16 people have not only
donated to Democrats but they have been
very active in the anti-trump movement
they all need to be questioned gore
frankly if their time sorry if they're
talking about Andrew McCabe there could
be some criminal issues involved here
too very strong criminal issues how I
intern how do we interpret dr. Gorka the
insurance policy that they discussed
with what who we think is Andrew McCabe
is the insurance policy when you look at
the time line that will just go after
Trump and will manufacture Trump Russian
collusion and that'll be the means to
take out a duly elected president if we
need to because we're smarter than
everybody else that voted for Donald
Trump
sure I'm not going to interpret
hypothesize or pass with individual
words in these technical text messages
mean we have enough evidence already and
I have to disagree with Pam it's not
about replacing individuals it's about
dissolving this team it isn't we now
know this team Mullis team is manned by
members of Hillary's so-called
resistance movement there's a reason
that Lady Justice is blindfolded in this
case she's taken her blindfold off
she's parties Ann and she's using that
sword to attack the president and one
crucial point where is Peter struck
today he the second these text messages
came out director rate should have gone
up to Peter stroke taken his gun taken
his badge and fired him from law
enforcement he is now in the HR
department of the Bureau think about
what you can do at the HR department is
he there massaging documents is he
hiding the political identities of other
people investigating the president this
isn't political bias this is corruption
at the highest level of law enforcement
how could he look at the team of Clinton
hate lovers Trump haters that have been
assembled the unethical proven behavior
of Andrew Weissman
how could he look at this team that he
is put together you know and then we
hear you know I want to believe the path
you threw out for consideration and
Andy's office that there's no way no way
Trump gets elected but I'm afraid we
can't take that risk it's like an
insurance policy in case you die before
you're 40 I can't interpret that as any
other way then deep state powerful
operatives scheming plotting and
planning to undermine an election tell
me where I'm wrong Pam Bondi
no and Sebastian you used much better
words than I that team does they need to
be dissolved and they need to be
investigated
I guess I'm holding out hope that rod
Rosenstein after listening to him
testify that he is lying he seen and
dated why doesn't he see the team can't
are you Sean I hope they're being
dissolved and I hope we see very soon
and dissolve this a much better word
Sebastian that this team needs to be
wipe every let me give you one of them
with that call me and struck there the
two guys that exonerated Hillary Clinton
we now know on the email server
investigation they exonerated her before
the investigation now that sounds like
obstruction to me by corrupt dr. Alka
Comey is corrupt struck is corrupt I
know rod Rosenstein I've met him he is a
quintessential bureaucratic survivor he
is going to skate along trying to make
everybody happy but he's not going to
change the fundamentally corrupt nature
of this team even a mother himself he's
a Vietnam vet he's got a sterling record
but maybe he's just utterly tone-deaf
you cannot have ten people that are
absolutely in the tank for Hillary
investigate the Republican president we
defeated Hillary I gave you the one
example I'll give you another example
what about the dossier how was it
possible four doors down from Roth
Rosenstein is a guy by the name of Bruce
or he's meeting with Fusion GPS as this
is all going on his wife is doing
anti-trump research for them four doors
down now Trump Russia collusion how
about Hillary paying for Russian
propaganda lies that were used in a
campaign to influence the American
people's that collusion Pam absolutely
absolutely but you can't blame
Rosenstein just because his office is
four doors down and again I'm not
defending him I'm saying I'm hoping he's
going to do the right thing I know him
I've worked with him all of these people
I agree need to be dissolved off this
investigation and he
said we're going to be seen something
very soon and that's what I'm hopeful
we're going to be seen because he's
supervising molar there's a bunch of
Watergate automate levels here by the
time we untangle this massive web of
corruption it will be worse than
Watergate it would be Watergate on human
growth hormone and steroids combined at
massive levels it's a banana republic
you're the one who had to untangle it
Sean not literal government it's sad and
the media is nowhere to be found they're
still locked into a one-year
investigation with zero evidence that's
how pathetic a doubt we would have had
today's hearing without you Sean Sarah
Carter John Solomon and some of our
colleagues here at Fox Catherine
Herridge and others it's literally a
small group and all of you thank you